[MUSIC]
Hi, I'm Wil Torres, Assistant Director
with Stanford GSB's MBA Admissions Office.
Today, we're joined by three students,
Sara, Jack and Marisabel,
who will share their experience
with the financial aid process.
Sara, Jack,
Marisabel, can you start off by telling
us a little bit about yourselves?
So let's start with where you're from and
what you were doing before
you came to the GSB.
>> So I was from Los Angeles and
running a charter school,
kindergarten through eighth grade and a
team of people who helped empower parents
of charter school kids from
disadvantaged communities in L.A.
>> Yep, so
I'm Jack,
I was in London before coming to the GSB.
I worked in turn around and structuring as
a consultant there and moved to the US for
the first time for business school.
>> I'm Marisabel, I was in
San Francisco right before the GSB,
grew up in Southern California.
Before business school, I was working in
tech on e-commerce and product management.
>> All right, so
let's talk about your journeys to the GSB.
Many prospects wonder if the opportunity
cost of taking time out from work to
pursue business degree is worth
the return on investment.
How did you come to the decision that
it was the right time for you and and
that it was worth it?
>> So I can go first.
I think for me, when I was
considering the opportunity cost,
I think I had a really interesting
conversation with a colleague of mine
who basically talked through it
being a marathon, not a sprint.
And I felt like I was trying
to sprint through work.
So I think that taking
the two years out to stop and
reflect was the first thing
that I really wanted to do.
And then I started to look into it and
did a lot of research online and
found a lot of useful articles that talked
about the kind off payoff periods and
the kind of transformative
experience it is.
So for me I was thinking about,
is the experience going to be worth it?
And then I was sort of
kind of running the numbers.
>> Great.
>> Similarly to Jack, I spoke to quite a
few different alumni, especially a handful
from the GSB, to talk about what their
experiences were paying off their loans.
because I really just wanted to
understand what that process looked,
like having never taken out loans before.
And so they helped me actually come
up with a model to look at different
pay off periods given conservative or
different salary ranges.
And for me,
it seemed very worth it and feasible.
And I also think less so
on the hard financial side but
more about looking at these two
years is a very efficient way
to understand what interests me and
what I wanted to pursue.
And that I just deemed very invaluable.
because I feel,
oftentimes when you're good at
something outside of business school or
in your professional life, you will keep
doing that because you're good at it.
But that doesn't necessarily mean that
that's what you want to be pursuing for
the rest of your life.
So I took both of those into
account in my decision to
to see that the investment was worth it.
>> Before I started my research,
I assumed it was just too late for
me to go business school.
I was nearing the end of my 30s and
relatively happy in my career,
it had always been a dream.
And a couple of conversations
with Alumni and
my executive coach led me
to realize that this one
year in the MSX program would
give me a chance to step up.
Probably wouldn't have the opportunity
to go in the future, and
it was a great time to do that.
>> Yeah, did you have any big
financial concerns coming into
the process of applying for
business school?
And how did you address
some of those concerns?
>> Yes, [LAUGH] I'll start.
I was certain I couldn't afford to
go to business school coming from
a background in nonprofit.
And looking at a few of the former
students who've gone here,
the alumni also who pursued
their MBAs elsewhere,
I just couldn't see how
the math would work out.
Until I learned about the loan
forgiveness program at Stanford and
was blown away by the flexibility and
the ability for
me to take advantage of that,
were I to continue to pursue
a career in a nonprofit.
>> A little bit more on
the loan forgiveness program.
Can you tell us a little bit about that,
and what gave you the confidence that
this was something that could help
support your career aspirations?
>> Well, when you're looking at programs,
aside from Stanford,
this program just doesn't exist.
And that was something I hadn't
really realized that at Stanford,
outside of Stanford,
I could take advantage of
the federal loan forgiveness program,
which is super restrictive.
It requires ten full years,
it has all these kind of catches to it,
the technical catches.
And few people are actually able
to take advantage of that program.
So when I learned more about that program,
I was so sad,
because I figured, gosh,
I really can't afford business school.
And then when I learned about Stanford,
their own loan forgiveness program,
I realized, okay, this makes sense.
For every six months,
I believe it's six months, increments or
a year increments, as long as you're
working in nonprofit position,
part time or full time,
that portion of your salary.
And there's a sliding scale as to what
your salary can be up to a certain point.
Percentage of that will be, of your loans,
your tuition, your living expenses,
all the loans you've taken
out will be forgiven.
And that to me was just such
an incredible benefit to
offsetting the cost that it would take for
someone from nonprofit
background here at Stanford.
>> Great, and then were there any other
concerns that you all had as you were
thinking about business school?
>> Yeah, I think for me, working in tech,
if you invest enough time
at a certain company,
there's a formula for
salary bumps and raises.
So my concern was, are the two years
outside of the professional space,
can I recoup that after
graduating business school?
So I just took a hard look at the past
figures, numbers of the salaries that
people earned right after business school,
especially Stanford GSB.
And kind of weighed that out with what
I would be earning had I stayed in
my role for these two years.
And just saw that I would
still be better off.
So that helped me a lot
with my decision as well.
Some other financial considerations,
I have been helping to support my
family also, leading up to this point.
So that was something that I
was very nervous about as well,
just how would I be able to do
that during business school?
But with the financial aid
that Stanford gave me,
that relieved a bunch of the pressure.
So both of those kind of just made it seem
much more feasible for me to still borrow
the money and then have enough money to be
able to support my family while in school.
>> Yeah, I definitely had
a lot of concerns coming in.
It was kind of my biggest worry about
deciding to come and do an MBA.
I was convinced that the experience would
be great, but whether I could afford it or
not was the challenge.
I think I spent a lot of times speaking
to the financial aid office ,who were
fantastic and gave me loads of support,
pointed me in all the right directions in
terms of thinking about where to get
loans as an international student,
what kind of conversations to be having,
and
then even just down to how much your
kind of daily costs are likely to be.
I think as well just the ease of
access to loans gave me confidence
that they had confidence that
I'd be able to pay them back.
So if it wasn't likely
they'll be able to afford it,
they wouldn't be lending me
the money as easily as they could.
Which I don't know if that makes sense,
but it did to me at the time.
>> So I actually did receive
a full ride at another business
school through their scholarship program.
Ultimately I decided to come to
the GSB because the financial aid was
still very generous.
But then also in working
with financial aid office,
they brought to light some of these
extra scholarship opportunities that
would be made available to me to apply to,
much like Sara covered.
And at the end of day, what I want
to pursue after business school I
felt like Stanford GSB could set
me up in the best way possible.
So I wasn't trying to optimize for
a completely free experience.
But I was trying to optimize for
something that would have
the best financial but
also personal ROI for myself.
>> Yeah, so I had some financial aid
from another school that I applied to.
And I think the deciding factor for
me was the generous amount that Stanford
financial aid package included.
And also, in the grand scheme of things,
I wanted the kind of best experience and
the most transformative experience.
And for me, that was always the GSB.
So even if the numbers were slightly
different, I think it was more about
if I'm going to make the investment,
it's making the right investment.
>> As you think about your
everyday experience here,
are there ways that you're able to be
thoughtful about either finances or
spending that still allow you
to maximize your time here?
>> Yeah, I would say that it's definitely
a conversation that people are having
more on campus now to create
a much more inclusive environment,
especially when it comes to clubs,
club dues, and those kinds of experiences.
You can raise a concern, and I've heard
that the financial aid office and
the student activities office have been
super helpful and receptive to that.
And I do think that there's so many
extracurricular activities, there's so
many options for how you want to
approach extracurricular activities.
So if you want to spend a little more on
this one trip or this one event you can.
But then there's so many other options
that you can also take advantage of and
still have a great time while at the GSB.
So I would say that there are range of,
I guess,
costs associated with all
the extracurriculars that you want to do,
so that we can create a much
more inclusive environment here.
>> Yeah, all right.
And as you're looking
back on your experience,
how would you advise prospective students
as they think about financial aid and
planning for business school?
>> I think the big thing for
me is that when it comes to planning,
is think about trying to give yourself
a bit of a buffer coming in, if you can.
I think you can take the loans, and
we talked about the financial aid and
how generous that is, and
you can run the numbers on the average
salary data post GSB and you'll be okay.
But I think my biggest challenge
was the initial cash flow,
which sounds a bit business schooly,
but just the flow of some of the funds.
So if you can find yourself
a little bit of a buffer coming in,
I think that would be my kind of advice or
tips in terms of how to think about it,
easing some of the stress early on.
>> Yeah, I would say that's exactly right,
especially in my case.
Having never taken out loans before,
and I tried to be a good budgeter
before business school, but maybe not
as reigned in as I would've liked.
Just looking at what your costs
were your first quarter here,
and just being realistic with yourself,
so not being too limiting or restrictive.
But just really understanding, okay, what
are the costs or how much am I going to
need to be able to support myself while
in business school this time, and
still give myself a little wiggle
room to enjoy my time here as well?
So I think at first I was very
restrictive, and that would stress me out.
But then,
once I would look back at the models, or
whatever I had done before to
show that this was worth it,
I was able to come up with a budget
that helped me thrive here at the GSB.
Yeah, in addition to having that
buffer before, planning for it after,
especially if you're in the Sloan or MSX
program, given that it's a full year and
we're fully engaged the year we are here.
Most of us are spending our summers
transitioning into a job and
don't have a job right away.
And that requires to have that buffer,
so absolutely.
I'd also suggest you just call
the financial aid office, talk to people,
talk to alumni, and
people will be really, really supportive.
There are some also financial planning
tools that you mentioned, sort of
modeling out your salary and knowing
you have that confidence given the ROI
you'll have based on your experience here,
that for me was incredibly helpful.
>> All right, any final words of
encouragement you might have for
applicants who are out there?
>> The GSB is so worth it.
Financial Aid will work with you.
They'll come up with packages,
like Jack said,
that they're confident
will help you succeed.
So I think it's such a good time
to just take a deep dive and
enjoy your time here, and know that
you'll be supported along the way.
>> Okay.
>> I'd also say it's an incredible
experience, so worth it.
And when you get here, to pay
attention to the small opportunities
to have an additional $20,000 scholarship.
There are these social innovation
certificates, for example,
you can apply for and then be eligible for
an additional grant that I wasn't
planning on and was able to get.
So absolutely like to pay attention
to the emails and the opportunities
to be a part of the financial aid
opportunities that exist here.
>> Yeah, I just, sort of, if I could
interrupt by saying it's been a truly
transformative experience so far and
I think there's only more to come.
And I'm kind of excited for the summer
to test out sort of what we're doing and
get back to the real world for
a bit and come back for next year.
So I think it's been worth every penny.
>> All right, and so
that's a great point to close on.
Great multiple points.
The time is worth it.
This is an investing in an experience and
your future career.
You can learn more about both the MBA and
the MSX program by visiting us
on the web at gsb.stanford.edu.
Thank you, and have a great day.
[MUSIC]